Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Resident Evil. Now, we've got Lucas here
Hey dumbass, don't turn around if you're stupid and an idiot
*laughs painfully at himself*
I really I really nailed him cova- *Drinks even more painfully*
woOOAHHH
Alright whatever. Alright, so, what we gonna do about this? Well, see ya. Hope he didn't hear that
Nahh how about this? Kerchunckle? why's he just giggling to himself? Doesn't make any sense
What the hell
Yeah, I'm glad you're so certain about my death and kalmick? klamick *confused noises*
common in
COMIC COMIC BOOK VILLAIN
METHODOLOGY!! Hey, buddy
Yeah
Yeah Lucas! Where ya goin'?
Aw you scared?
Ooooh no little baby all scared
Uh-oh OH oh-oh
Wow, he put that up in a quickie
Alright, I killed off all the Connections' researchers
They were poking around where they weren't supposed to when I wasn't looking, but I knew exactly what they were up to. Probably didn't have
Like having room to report to me
So, I threw them in a cage with some Molded. They shit their pants and begged for their lives. I'm just worried
I won't be able to hold back from laughing when I make the report that they've met with an unfortunate accident
Probably a good time to cut ties with the connection. I'm the only one who can really make good use of Eveline's mold
Okay
That's weird. What's with all the mannequin heads though? Why is he obsessed with mannequin heads? Okay what am I seeing here?
I saw something - oh save alright then
ookayy
Cool, mkay, anything else here? What's over here?
Hey uh I unlocked it!
Oh, that's the way back okay?
Handgun ammo, buyer for data got one?
Get set up for transmission? Who's buying?
Please tell me it's Umbrella Corporation because that would make total sense because I don't trust Umbrella Corporation even if they did restructure
Something just tells me there's bad news all over the place. Oh yeah, I forgot about that guy. Um
Uh - oof - uh, how about a grenade? Would that work? I don't think it'd work. Would it work? It wouldn't work
I -
Nah
Wait
Oh it doe - oh, it doesn't have any bullets. Oh
Okay, well, that's handy
Well, that was just for scares, then he doesn't have anything left
OH NO
Alright fine then
Hello? Ooh
He should have gone here - he would  have found some bullets
Oh, you know -
Okay
Uh-huh
Nah - oh whoa why whoa what the fuck?
Well alright then, do I just gotta kill you?
Well, he ain't gonna die
Eugh
Eugh, but I don't wanna be fucking screwed
Why am I still on him?!?
W - why was he still - ?
Eugh - why were they still straddling him? Why was it straddling him in the first place?
Wait what's happening?
Oh okay oh
Ohh I just let that happen then. Did I?
Agh
Eugh gross
Ahh that's big! Oh
Well I don't know about that
Ohh - ee - whoa you are weird-lookin'. Alright what do you do buddy?
How can I AHHAH END IT?
aiee ay
I don't like any of what you're doing right now, how about you take one of theeese?
Waboom
And another one of theese?
Can I punch you? Is that an option?
Can I punch you? Whoa whoa leapfrog alright
Oo I gunna punch you. Oh, I'm so gonna punch you. Ah wait. Why can't I punch you? Oh shit. That's not punchable.
Uh-oh, yay, I thought he was gonna leapfrog again, oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
Okay
Ayee
Oh goddamn, where's it going? Come on stop skedaddling all over the - woooooooah
Okay, ye that's too much skedaddle
I don't know why I closed my eyes for a bit to let you do whatever you're doing right now
But, something tells me now in retrospect that might have been a terrible idea. Euh, it's so goopy on the ceiling
Let me see what's in here. Ooh hey
Uh-oh - WAAAAAAAGH
Hey, how about you don't do that?
WAAGH
OWW *laugh*
WOOOO that hurt a lot, okay well
Options are
What?
Dickin' nil?
Yee - oh got ya
bap blap blap woah uh-oh, uh-oh
Oh he don't look so good. Is he still alive? Is he dying? Oh yeah he's still alive. Not dying. Everything I said was wrong
Okay. Woah, that's a lot of contamination
Yes a little weird, huh
What does that mean? What the hoo - thank you I - I guess
I dunno how that works and why that was set up in here just for such an occasion as this, but I'll take it sure
OWWW
Okay, I gotta use those once I'm really low not when I'm like at sixty. I didn't know that
Yeah, yeah, yeah get it. What if I use my super bullets on you? Is it gonna work?
Or is it gonna be just a waste?
Now I'll wait until I run out I guess
AHHHHH
Yeah, I hate it when you do the leapfrog thing it doesn't bode well for me
Oh boy, am I starting to run low okay here we go. Super bullets
ho
Baby don't like that. Oh you do not
The answer is a negative on that one alright I'm gonna go get some oxygen
*Poor imitation of annoying woman*
???? I KNOW god i know
Whoa hey whoa hey euuuh
Okay
God how much do you need? This is supposed to be at like - oh I'm out of everything
WOOAAAH
Okay, well, this is a problem. I - I got a whole lot of nothing whoo
That did nothing. Okay, alright well here we go
What? Really? I killed him with that? *Laughs*
Hell yeah, go Lucas
Oh yeah you
You deserved that one. I don't know how I did that with a knife
But I just gonna assume that it's because I'm an incredible badass
So unbelievably awesome in everything I do yeah, I didn't have any bullets left, but
Shoot? Woah pfft. I didn't have a shotgun left, but okay, I'll take it
Uhh - huh
Oh no. No it's not it's like 50% come on
Shoot the computer?
There you go there you go, yeah, Chris being a smart
Uh-huh
Ahh gets infected immediately
Yeah makes sense
Ah I guess I should have finished in the last episode, but that does - OOOohhh
Is it Wesker? Is it Wesker? Tell me it's Wesker
Wait who's packing up all this shit?
So while I was down in the mines, while I was down in the mines dying
With all my team of the four of us, that's all we really did when things would go p-- that bad
They were just packing up. Alright that's fascinating
Okay, but it's not over. This episode is not over yet, because I'm gonna roll right into the very next
Uhhhh, the next DLC Thor's hammer site B, ooh
Okay, well, I don't - I don't need any of that. I'm going into the next one, with Joe
Alright nanananana get outta here. We don't need this
We don't need none of that because we got the next one lined up right now extra content
End of Zoe. If you remember what happened to Zoe in like the - the main storyline if y - you - you had a choice there
But Zoe got consumed into this weird
Crystalline thing and it wasn't really evident what that was. Anyway, new game
Normal, I'm good for normal difficulty. I know what I'm doing
So here
We go
Oh yeah, oh, this is the moment yeah
I had to use my head. There's only one left
It's fine
It was perfect. I'm sure there's someone who can help this is my home
Apparently I belong I'll send help
Don't bother
There won't be anyone left to help
Uh-oh
Yeah that. If you pick Evie to get the thing she - that happens
And I don't know what that is and I don't know why Evelyn's doing that to her sister, but uh?
No no no, that's bad.
Uh-oh
Zoe Baker she's still breathing. Calling HQ
Wow. Okay, not smart. Wow okay?
How did - ?
What - how did you punch out two helmeted soldiers?
Listen to me. We're here to help
No, I don't believe you boy
Tell me what kind of help comes you know helicopter gunship
You don't know what you're talking about you. Don't get it you think I don't know who you people are
With all these monsters running around here. Tell me where'd they come from
It's not what you think you don't understand, I don't understand
You see the girl back there look
That damn my brother's little girl
My niece you want to stand
here
Family is a righteous talk
And you ain't gonna kill my family
See daddy something I can abide
fuck's sake
She's infected. She's dying and we're both gonna fuckin die
right now I
Ain't dead yet boy so I figure you better do something about it for I feel you two little friends outside, okay?
There's a cure your lie to me
We were on our way to get her treatment, and you fuck that up when you jumped us I
Probably still waiting for us right now
Where
Man he's a big, muscular, southern man. That is -
i am tall. Is this what it's like to be tall? I'm so big. Zoe
No, it's awfully convenient that this weird crystalline growth covered your boobs and almost a skirt like thing so
That's nice I guess. Are you - just stay there
Big guy's gonna go splorin' *laughs* my - my journal that was no gator
I saw today. Was out checking the lines when I saw I had one
I saw pulled it up. Instead it was some sludge covered god knows what with huge teeth and claws
Tried to get at me so I punched the fucker teeth then before dude never thought I'd see with my own eyes
Goddamn, government doing secret experiments on people and animals no doubt about it
Explains those helicopter flying around recently. Well this doesn't make sense because if he's been living around here
His brother is - and the whole family has been infected for like years now, like two years wasn't it?
Was he not paid a visit ever since? What is that? Oh?
Oh *Laughs* Aw
BAM boom boom boom boom boom boom boom go and getcha
*Laughs* *Incoherent* Am I just gonna be - ?
Am I just gonna be - whoa - ow, what the hell? Came at me, it came at me. Oh
Yah, gotta keep my guard up. Yeah, I gotta keep my guard up like this. That's really gonna do it for me
*Laughs*
Please tell me this is just gonna be all fisticuffs. Oh yes. Oh yes. Oh yeah
Joe
Yes, Joe. Oh
Joe you - you big bastard. Oh, yes, oh
Joe *Laughs*
Yeah, what's this? Okay, Joe biker
LCS *Incoherent*
Alright
How to kill those things: bodies are tough, but heads are soft - punch them *Laughs*
Get in as many fast punches as possible left right right with some fast right jabs works good
Right, left right then a strong left knocks him out. Heads crushed easily underfoot when they fall down. Crouch and sneak up behind
When not looking to take them out without a fight (Jeez can you not read the screen? -_-)
I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. Oh I love it. Oh I
Love it
Love it! Mm do I need to visit the outhouse? Left right right?
Oo - OOOH, *laughs* oh this is the best! Hello?
Ah
*Laughs*
I got a *laughs again*
You mix critter with chem fluid. I'm a scientist
I will make goop juice out of this. Just take a grub, you wrap it in some chems
And you got sweet goop juice *spitting noises* So put it everywhere
Ain't gonna be no problems with you when you got grub juice. Ooh
Is that a gator? I have you know I got my gator football championship - what did I get? I don't even know - grub!
Get our critter, where did I find that? Man if he's in another -
Oh yeah, alright!
*Insert noises here*
Yeah!
Oh my god
Oh wow
Whoops that is the map. How do I get the map up? What the hell - AHHH! Hang on wait - I'm crouching apparently - I'll finish her!
BOOOOOOOM!
Wow, okay, that doesn't seem efficient, but you know it is awesome as all hell alright
Let me just get some of this grub juice cuz I wasn't thinking
*Insert more noises here*
Okay, that's good right on my hitting hand
I call this hitty and I call this fisty don't make hitty and fisty mad
Hitty and fisty gonna give you the old two three. We're gonna skip right over one. Oh, yeah
Oh, yeah, you don't see me behind this poison ivy do ya? Do you son? Here comes fisty!
*Laughs*
I called it the stealthy kill
real quiet-like *laughs*
Oh that one didn't even know nothing about my silent taunt afterwards. It's a real quiet die motherfucker
Yeah, nobody know ain't nobody know *laughs*
This is the greatest thing I have ever seen in my entire life
I'm the greatest thing where's me some grub?
And grabbing this tree huh? I need more chem fluid before I'm able to make the goop juice I need
Break it, brap it, blap-a-dapper
Oh - oh dat that my hit'n doll?
Collect effigies to boost your attack. Yeah
Gotta get these hitting sticks. I call - I call this Hitty wh - same as my lefty Hitty
Fisty this is also Hitty. Look at him. Oh look at Hitty go
I call this tiny punchy paw
*Laughs*
*More Laugh*
You sack of shit alright mmm grub fluid got some grub piss. It's just piss. That's all his grub
ggggGGGRRUUUUUBBB?!?!
Yes, got a critter - got that goop juice grub juice
Uh-ooooh, I got a flashlight apparently
*INSERT ALL THE NOISES*
Someone trying to punch you through the wall?
Huh?
You ain't gonna punch it through - ooh hey. Hello friend
You look like you could use some punches - cure for E-type infection. Well. I don't know rightly what that means but?
Alright
Eugh
What das- that's right, that's good dude tHAT GRUB
Oh, he already made his own grub juice. Well that's gross, but oh well
Uh-oh
Ayayayay right!
*Laughs* Those were some faster. Oh don't grab you right around your head grab you right on your doooong
What? I heard that
Who did that?
Hello grub grub (x 100). Oh would you grub, grub? Oh?
Get some from Fisty get some from Hitty
Ooh baby!
Hitty-fisty party, alright whoa hey grub grub
Grub grub grub grub grub. No no no, aw naw
Ah nah! *Laughs*
I love this so much. It's so fun. Who's there? Who's there?
Huh?
Alright, well now that I learned ya somethin' good y'ain't gonna go back now to my home
That's what I know for 113n(?)
100% certain
That guy back home probably dead, cuz I left him - woah
Don't know the power of Fisty and Hitty. I done punched the air and it made that - fall. Uh-oh
Maybe I shouldn't have let - my gators!
Oh god!
Oh I'm hitting gators? Ooooh nooo
It's Hitty and Fisty - OH AND LARRY!
Oh Steve oh damn it. damn it damn it Dagny. Oh
Well this ain't good, but okay. Priorities first.
That's the proper insertion point for cures, I know this
Kay?
Well that doesn't make sense
Oh wha - ah - that ain't good - critter! Grub!
Critters! Critters! Grab the critters! Grab 'em grab 'em grab 'em man!
Aww you let all the critters get away!
Woah! Hey!
You ain't a critter!
Aww you critter food now
Huh. Can't worry about that none. Definitely not my fault. *Laugh* right, come on. Come along, Zoe
Hey! That's mine!
Alright, cya
I can't - oh man!
Hitty and fisty are all used up right now. Alright fine. Let's go-tuh-grab-that-stuff-now
It's still by the fire Zoe
alright, see
Yeah no joke huh? Maybe you shouldn't have punched those GOVernment employEEs
Is it okay? I don't seem okay. I'm just gonna guess by the- Conflagration and the- the ominous zombie standing right there
You wan - you wanna go wi - ? Oh - oh, you want some of hitty and fisty? Oh you come find me!
Hmm you come find me x2
He'll find me. He knows where I live.
Wait a minute!
Hmm, he blew up where I live. That ain't good. Ok!
Dead soldier boy. By the way, he's dead. Very dead. Wanna clarify that, he's very, extremely dead.
Although not sure didn't check. He might have got some grub juice on him.
Huh, good question.
You know, if this guy just didn't interfere, everything would be hunky dorey
Somebody
Okay
You gonna punch your way through him this time?
Ooh, that's a good slurp. I don't like the sound of that slurp
Cluuuunnk!
Alright. Yeah they got that wall up fast. Holy hell. Also again, what- what is this guy?
This guy was just punching, punching for the past two years straight.
Like just in self - reclusiveness.
Just isolated away, only punching. Forever and ever.  Alright, Zoe
I don't know where we're going and I don't know why but okay? I'm not staring at your boob. I'm just looking where I'm step- woah!
Not now, gator
Alright
Here I go
I'll punch you later, gator.
Gatahhhh!
*snarls from said gator*
That's not good. Ah! Hey come on, come on now. Be nice.
Uh I don't know about that. There's a conveniently nice couch here. Why's there just a couch here?
Uh I don't know about that. Oh no
Mm but I'll save okay whoo-hoo almost punched that save and whOOPS almost destroyed it before I recorded my- oppp whelp there goes *giggles*
Thank you everybody so much for watching. I'm out of time for this episode, but I appreciate you guys being here.
and this is gonna be a fun one.
So thanks again, Let me know what you think down below in the comment below, and as always, I will see you in the next video.
Buh-Byeeee!